c'est très difficile pour quelqu'un de
savoir ce qui se passe en france la
seule manière de savoir ce qui se passe
dans un pays c'est de construire des
outils qui permettent de faire un bilan
régulier à l'échelle de 70 millions
d'habitants et un demi million de
kilomètres carrés c'est ça la question
chacun dans sa vie ne peut pas faire
l'expérience des tendances nationales
il n'existe que sur une base statistique
dans les sondages et vu ces sondages
si vous prenez une des questions il ya
40% des gens qui trouvent que le terme
est bon d'autres qui trouvent qu'il est
pas assez forts d'autres trop fort il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui trouvent
que les choses vont mal donc ils sont
pas dans l'analyse étymologique
ils sont pas dans l'analyse de la
criminalité au plan historique au plan
comparatif il trouve qu'il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui va pas le ministre
le dit et à ce moment-là il acquiesce
qu'ils ont avec l'utilisation du terme
c'est pas le même type de deux d'examen
des termes et des faits
[Musique]